Now let's take a look at how
the initiator and responder and
authenticate that key exchange.
Both the initiator and
responder compute a hash value
using a pseudorandom function.
And the input key is the real secret,
which is based on their pre-shared
key and the nonce values
that they have exchanged.
The input block data contains the
information that they have exchanged,
such as the public components
the Diffie-Hellman key exchange,
the cookies, the crypto
algorithms that they offer, and
the identity of the initiator and
responder.
Each party can verify the hash value
computed by the other because the hash
values are based on a pre-shared key,
and the information they just exchanged.
Therefore, these hash values can
authenticate both parties identities and
the data that they have just exchanged.